now uh that breaking news that we had in
the past few minutes Cristiano Ronaldo
is to leave Manchester United at his
club with immediate effect our Sports
correspondent Rob Harris uh joins me
once again uh
from Doha and Rob I just wonder your
reaction to this news which I guess was
inevitable
yeah it did seem so once Cristiano
Ronaldo gave that interview last week
saying he felt betrayed by Manchester
United criticizing the club the
standards of coaching criticizing the
methodology and the fabric of the club
it looked like his time at Manchester
United was coming to an end this is the
end of his second period of the club
he'd barely been there a year or so
United thought he was heading to
Manchester City when they signed him a
year ago but they managed to convince
him Sir Alex Ferguson the former manager
who managed to convince him not to go to
their Arch Rivals but it has been a
sowering of relations his 37 years old
and he's not quite had the same impact
we have had a statement just now from
Cristiano Ronaldo and he confirmed in it
that following conversations with
Manchester United we have mutually
agreed to end our contract early he says
I love Manchester United and I love the
fans that will never ever change however
it feels like the time right for me to
seek a new challenge he concludes the
statement by saying I wish the team
every success for the remainder of the
season and for the future he had not
been a significant part of this season
only one goal scored and he'd even left
some games early and that led to him at
one point being banished from the team
for a while but will United fans
remember him for this second spell at
the club or for the first period when he
really made his mark from 2003 to 2009
winning champions league Premier League
titles and being part of that Alex
Ferguson period of dominance but for now
Ronaldo is here in Qatar focused on his
Portugal team who start their World Cup
campaign on Thursday against Ghana
Ronaldo will be looking for a new club
no details on what it means in terms of
this Mutual consent will United have to
pay up the rest of the contract or has
it been ripped up that's been determined